>> Juan: WELCOME BACK.
THE MEDIA BIG THUMBS UP TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN SPEECH.
>> AFTER FOUR YEARS OF A
MONOTONE CHILD, IT WAS BRACING
TO HEAR A SPEECH DELIVERED AT
TIMES BY A WHISPER.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS A REMARKABLE
SPEECH.
>> HE IS REALLY TRYING TO BRING
THE COUNTRY TOGETHER.
IT WAS MAKE AMERICA FEEL
GOOD NIGHT.
MAKE AMERICA FEEL PRIDE NIGHT.
>> I THOUGHT THE SPEECH WAS
CAREFULLY AND SMARTLY CRAFTED IN
A POLITICAL WAY.
>> Juan: BUT THE MEDIA HAD A
MUCH HARSHER TAKE ON
SENATOR TIM SCOTT DO REBUTTAL.
>> A SPEECH WHERE FACTS DON'T
MATTER WHICH IS WHERE THE
CURRENT REPUBLICAN PARTY
RESIDES.
>> I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE PURPOSE
OF THIS WAS.
I'M SHOCKED AND A LITTLE BIT
EMBARRASSED FOR HIM.
THIS WAS A LOST OPPORTUNITY.
>> HE DOES NOT SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND, AND A LOT OF THEM
DON'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A RACIST
COUNTRY IN A SYSTEMIC RACISM.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO GET THE
DIFFERENCE.
>> Juan: DANA, LET'S GO BACK
TO TIM SCOTT'S SPEECH.
I WANT TO ASK YOU IF YOU THINK
IT WILL ELEVATE HIM.
I REMEMBER WITH FRED THOMPSON
AWAY BACK COMMIT PUT FRED
THOMPSON ON THE MAP AS A
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
IT DID NOT DO THAT FOR
MARCO RUBIO OR BOBBY JINDAL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT DOES FOR
TIM SCOTT?
>> Dana: AGAIN, I THINK DOING
THE REBUTTAL IS VERY, VERY HARD
AND ONLY SOMEBODY WITH
ORATORICAL SKILLS.
>> Greg: YOU DON'T WANT SOME
HELP FROM ME.
I WILL SAY SOMETHING TERRIBLE.
>> Dana: YES, NO DOUBT HE IS
NOW ELEVATED.
EVERYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT HIM.
SOMETIMES, UNFORTUNATELY
TRENDING NEGATIVELY WITH RACIAL
SLUR WILL ELEVATE YOU, FOR
EXAMPLE KAMALA HARRIS WAS ASKED
ABOUT HIS COMMENTS LAST NIGHT.
BY ROBIN ROBERTS ON
"GOOD MORNING AMERICA," TIM SAID
IT'S NOT A RACIST COUNTRY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
SHE SAID I AGREE THIS IS NOT A
RACIST COUNTRY BUT WE HAVE
ISSUES WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
AND WHAT IS TIM SCOTT DOING, HE
IS ACTUALLY GOING UP ROLLING UP
HIS SLEEVES AND WORKING ON
RACISM.
IT DEFINITELY ELEVATES HIM.
IT IS INTERESTING SOMEBODY IN
THE MEDIA HAD THAT REACTION.
LAST NIGHT, FIRST OF ALL, PETER
WAS REALLY ANNOYING ME BECAUSE
BEFORE HAND, FLIPPING THROUGH
THE CHANNELS, TALK ABOUT THE
NETFLIX SERVING A LITTLE BIT.
AND THEN I HAVE TO WATCH THE
SPEECH.
HE READ A BOOK AND THEN FROM THE
PEANUT GALLERY.
LET'S JUST SAY SOME PEOPLE DID
NOT LIKE THE SPEECH.
SPEED TO GREG TO COME I DON'T
THINK YOU LIKE THE SPEECH FROM
WHAT I HEARD EARLIER, BUT I
WANTED TO ASK YOU IF YOU COULD
AGREE THAT THE PRESIDENT DID
SEEM TO BE IN COMMAND, ALERT,
NOT SOME DODDERY OLD GUY, WHICH
IS A LOT OF THE CONSERVATIVE
COMPLAINT.
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT GOT BLOWN
AWAY.
>> Greg: THE PRESIDENT WAS
ALERT, PROBLEM SOLVED.
HE WAS CONSCIOUS.
NO, I THINK THE REAL NEWS HERE
IS THAT JOY REID CAN BE
EMBARRASSING.
NO NEW.
>> Dana: GOOD POINT.
>> Greg: WE HAD TO CODE JOYS
AND THEY WERE BOTH JOYLESS.
THE MEDIA IS IN CHARGE OF THE
NATION'S NARRATIVE SO WHEN
GENERALLY REVEALING SOMETHING
HOW WELL THEIR NARRATIVE IS
EFFECTIVELY SPREAD FEAR AND SO I
USED TO THINK THE MEDIA WAS THE
BULLHORN FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
IT IS ACTUALLY THE OPPOSITE.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY IS THE FOOT
SOLDIER FOR THE POWERFUL PEOPLE
IN MEDIA.
THEY ARE GIVEN THE TALKING
POINTS AND INTERCHANGEABLE WITH
WHAT YOU WOULD SEE ON CNN AND
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SEE COMING FROM
THE DEMOCRATS.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS IT IS
COMING FROM THE MEDIA NOW AND
NOT THE POLITICIANS.
>> Juan: SO JESSE, I WAS
STRUCK THAT BIDEN MADE A POINT
THAT YOU HAVE MOSTLY GOOD POLICE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND THEN I SAW MAXINE WATERS
APPLAUDING.
SO TO ME, THAT LOOK LIKE A
UNIFYING GESTURE.
HOW DID IT LOOK TO YOU?
>> Jesse: I WAS HAPPY THAT
EVERYBODY CLAPPED, BUT I THINK
GREG MADE A GOOD POINT.
WHEN GREG ACTUALLY MAKES A GOOD
POINT, I THINK WE SHOULD
RECOGNIZE THAT.
THE STUDENT.
BUT JUAN IN THE LETTER A BLOG,
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE GROUP
LOWEST RATED BY ABOUT
20 MILLION.
AND YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO WHO STRAIN
THINGS FOR A DECADE.
I DON'T THINK STREAMING JUST
STARTED THIS YEAR.
I'M DISAPPOINTED IN ANDREA
MITCHELL AND MARTHA AND BRIAN
WILLIAMS AND HERE IS WHY, JUAN.
THEY HAVE COVERED OR OBSERVED, I
DON'T KNOW COME WITH A DELIVERY
OF RONALD REAGAN, BILL CLINTON'S
CHARISMATIC STEM, GEORGE W. BUSH
IS DEFINING LANGUAGE AFTER 9/11,
BARACK OBAMA'S SOARING AND
DONALD TRUMP'S SHOWMANSHIP AND
PATRIOTIC LANGUAGE.
AND THEY WILL LOOK AT
JOE BIDEN'S SPEECH AND SAY THAT
WAS REMARKABLE?
JUAN THAT IS LIKE WATCHING A
FOOTBALL GAME WITH PONDS, SAYING
THAT IS THE GREATEST GAME I'VE
EVER SEEN.
YOU WOULD THINK JIM NANTZ WAS A
IF HE TOLD YOU THAT.
YOU ARE SAYING IT WAS GOOD
BECAUSE HE PROMISED TO SPEND
MORE MONEY THAN ANYBODY EVER?
IS THAT THE BAROMETER RIGHT NOW?
SOMEONE CAN TAX AND SPEND REALLY
WELL?
THAT IS EASY.
THERE IS NO CREATIVITY.
THERE IS NO INNOVATION THERE.
HE IS BUYING VOTES AND
REDISTRIBUTING THE WEALTH.
ANYBODY CAN DO THAT.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO GIVE THIS GUY
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE BECAUSE HE
TAKES OUR MONEY AND GIVES IT
AWAY AND MAKES MORE PEOPLE
DEPENDENT?
COME ON, JUAN, THIS WASN'T A
GREAT SPEECH.
THIS WAS BAD TO.
>> Juan: I DON'T AGREE, BUT I
WILL TAKE YOUR POINT AND GO TO
KATIE.
KATIE, LET'S FORGET THE
ABUNDANCE THEN.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SAID THEY
LIKE THE SPEECH IN THE POLLS.
>> Katie: LET ME SEE IF I CAN
DO THIS CORRECTLY.
IT WAS THE MOST UNIFYING SPEECH
SINCE THE CIVIL WAR AND
EVERYBODY WHO CRITICIZED
TIM SCOTT IS A RAGING RACIST AND